a key reason why relationships are
valuable is that they help us to know
ourselves better being part of a couple
can help us to understand who we are our
partners may see what we no longer can
both what's adorable and what's more
perplexing and difficult they might for
example remind us that we've told that
anecdote three times before or that
purple doesn't suit us they can tell us
that we've overreacted to a problem at
work or that we've placed our trust in
an envious friend their responses to us
give us a chance to grow slightly less
obtuse hay and
peculiar but despite the potential of
love to function as a root to self-
knowledge in practice we often walk away
from relationships with most of our
delusions intact some of our problem
comes down to Pride we can't find it in
our hearts to forgive our lovers for
catching sight of material that doesn't
Accord with what we want to be true of
ourselves we come to love hoping to be
admired they spot that we aren't always
very funny that our novel is patchy that
we're prone to self-pity that we lose
our tempers too fast far from using
these bits of difficult news as gos for
self-improvement we tend to find it much
easier to get insulted to say that a
partner is being mean or inconsiderate
and to block our ears we fall back on a
noxious but highly popular idea about
love that in a good relationship no one
should be trying to change anyone
presumably because we're perfect enough
already we're not only bad at receiving
feedback we're also very poor at giving
it we give up after only a few minutes
of measured conversation call them a
slam the door and Shout that
they're as bad as their mother or father
in order to capitalize on the potential
of relationships we should be stricter
on certain basic rules for love firstly
we should start by by insisting contrary
to the Romantic script that true love is
entirely compatible with attempts to
teach people who they are and how they
might improve the only people whom we
don't want to change are those we don't
care about secondly at the same time
huge attention should be paid to the way
we share our insights we must become the
most willing of students and the kindest
of teachers we should only strive to
dulge tricky things when we aren't
smarting from our contact with them we
need to strike always when the iron is
cold thirdly we should soften our
verdicts with recourse to words like
perhaps and maybe we should say that we
feel that they may be missing something
not that we and our therapist and our
mother are certain of their Insanity we
should remember that emotional truths
can only ever be heard in an atmosphere
of intimate
safety most relationships collapse
because in the end two people didn't
want to know more about themselves
because the knowledge was too hard and
because the way it was shared was too
tough given how much precious
psychological information every
relationship throws up we should share
our hard want insights with unlimited
tenderness and strive to hear them
always with trust curiosity and courage